I wanted to get a day job this was on a
20 some odd years ago and and I'd had a
business with my folks was a small print
and copy shop I knew nothing about it
but I took all the failures of my other
businesses and and did the opposite of
that and did really well with it and we
were able to raise the business up quite
a bit
drive you know make it much more
profitable and my folks were able to
sell it off and retire and so I thought
well you know I'll go see about this
copier job so I went to this company up
shall remain nameless and for an
interview and I walked in she goes oh
just fill out the application and you
know mr. X will see you shortly and I
was like oh no that's okay I'm not I
don't fill out the application I've
already got my you know CV with me my
whatever she's kind of looked at me sat
down waited like a chance to go and sat
down with mr. X really nice man and it
was the job was just it was terrible
they're gonna give me the worst I know
what they're gonna do they're gonna be
the worst territory and it's gonna be
business them you know business business
sales and I'm gonna try to get them to
buy copiers from this company and the
the pay was gonna be nothing there
wasn't gonna be a car allowance or
cellphone allowance or a laptop
allowance or insurance or any you know
benefits or medical or dental or
anything and I was like that you know I
get it I know the drill but I'll show my
worth and you know things will change
well we've done this listening exercise
in an acting class I was doing at the
time and and it was really mind-blowing
and when we did it for me it was because
I had an experience with the actress
that I was working with that that night
and I just watched this whole shift
occur in her I didn't say anything she
was just talking and I was listening
with a hundred percent focus which by
the way just doing that it's almost it's
exhausting the first time you do it but
it was also really interesting and
liberating and so I thought I'm gonna
try that today so instead of this
interview and we say a few pleasantries
back and forth
and he says well tell me about yourself
I go well you know there's a lot of you
say about myself but you know I would
really like to hear like what your
biggest challenges are who's been great
at this job who's not being great at
this job anything that you could share
with that be really helpful to me and I
don't want to waste your time and and I
certainly wouldn't dream of wasting your
time I think that was like that would
the totality of what I said and then I
didn't say another word for 45 minutes
and he just started to talk it was a
little bit like you know I could see him
as my lane what the hell is this right
yeah who is this guy right which would
you know it's actually like a really
smart move I wasn't trying to be smart
or anything or saying I'm necessarily
smart but anyway all I did for the next
45 minutes is like mm-hmm
oh really Wow but I was actively
listening there are things you can do
and we'll get into it here that you you
train yourself to actively listen and
eye contact total focus and I'm
literally hearing everything you're
saying and I did that for 45 minutes
with this guy and he just kept opening
up more and more and smile came across
his face about five minutes in and it
wouldn't leave 20 minutes in he's
telling me funny stories and anecdotes
about his family and stuff and it just
kept on going at about the 45 minute
mark I remember that well because you
know what man
I'm not gonna give you this position I
can't this position man you're better
than this I can't do that to you and
that broke me for a second I didn't
speak but I was like what did he just
say and I went right back to listen to
him goes listen man this is the worst
this is the worst position I'll tell you
what I want you to come and meet the
president of the company company he's
got to meet you hang on one second and
he got ugly and I was like oh my god
what's going on
it goes down he gets the president he
calls me like we walked down at the
president's office and introduces the
guy and the guys like oh I heard great
things about you yeah we'd love to have
you on board and I've given him full
full authority to give you you know this
route and out of this district this
territory I'm like okay well great nice
to meet you
they sat me down and they offered me
this like really great job I mean there
was
first thing was like a $30,000 a year
job and I ended up they offered me like
I want to say eighty five thousand a
year plus bonuses and Commission which
were end up being I don't know like
around 150 a year maybe more this is you
know 20-some odd years ago with a car
with insurance with the cellphone with a
laptop full benefits right out of the
gate in one of their best territories
did you take it no no - and there's two
reasons why number one I was stunned I
couldn't believe that just happened
I I was just doing this acting listening
exercise that this is Wow and I was just
kind of tripping because of what had
happened with the actors and I when we
were doing this exercise the night
before both of us fully aware of what
was going on but she couldn't help it
she the same thing that happened to her
on a much more personal level happen in
the room with that gentleman with mr. X
and I just Wow and I thought about like
I can't do that yeah that's like it
that's a job job man what am I gonna go
do this I can't take time off and work I
can't go to audition in the middle of
the day when they're I can't do that and
so I you know respectfully decline he
goes don't listen I you're a winner
you're on your I didn't say anything I
just listen to the man
did you ever think about that job if
there were a few bumpy times and say I
should have taken it or were you even
glad when there were bumpy times I'm
glad I never because that's a full
committed career well yeah there he was
like me listen you you'd have my job I'm
kind of glad he said you'd have my job
in six months if you were here I can see
it in your eyes I dunno I probably a
mixture of both back and forth you know
when I was like oh my god but on eclis
when I decided not to take that job I
just kind of went on a tear and started
working back to back to back to back to
back and yeah but yeah I mean that would
have been nice in a lot of ways I
remember there's that you know the class
I was in that occurred I mentioned to
the guy who was teaching the class about
that and he's are just a real like
wrestling with his own demons well
that's all I'll say was no he's the most
pleasant cat which was one of the
reasons I like I can't be with this guy
and it was kind of a bittersweet because
I this exercise that we had done I
thought this is so amazing
however you know the personality leaves
so much to be desired I don't want to be
around that anymore so but I this time
getting ahead of myself so I told the
guy what had happened in this you know
job interview like four or five days
before and he looks and he goes don't do
that stay in this business you stay here
keep doing this and I was like the
nicest thing he'd ever said and I was
like we're first of all where the hell
did that come from
thank you but where the hell did that
come from I was like I don't know it was
interesting interesting it's interesting
when you have someone that doesn't have
to be nice to you and they end up giving
you a compliment I think it's oh yeah it
is you're right but I think that guy
should be nice because he's taking money
from people to provide a service and
behaving
sort of that yeah sure I'm not that guy
I'm not I hear you I can't be around
that that I can't be around that guy or
that gal
you